foreign
qualified to lead
no
what makes a man qualified to lead
if he's assertive he's a good decision
maker he's a great Problem Solver like
you know he's a great protector leader
provider I think some men's personality
like the alphas of the world are just
mentally and I know some betas that are
just
quiet not uh extroverted not don't have
those leadership qualities I think there
are two separate pools of men that that
just don't have those Alpha qualities
not necessarily that it's a bad thing
it's not something I would personally
want but you know not all men are meant
to be that strong leader and maybe they
do maybe they are Mama's Boys in need
uh need those strong women I don't know
I think this is a good question so not
all men know a kennel man with the right
mentorship yes and it's it's it's three
simple things it's he's sure himself
he's sure of where he's going he can
Inspire others to see that Vision if he
could do those things then he can
catalyze anybody to follow up so that's
a really good definition yeah I would
agree with it yeah like they summed it
up yeah he stole it yeah it's like the
question is what do women do because
there's only so many Alphas or men that
can lead so what are women supposed to
do some of y'all need to know y'all's
place and not everybody can get that
outfit I was about to say it man yeah
that's the problem that Kevin Samuel
show so wait let me ask the question
because this I hate this Alpha and beta
talk
um how are we defining Alpha like
amongst men or Alpha amongst men and
women
I would say both
yeah because then technically then and
and hear me also technically wouldn't
every man be an alpha compared to a
woman but he's just not an alpha
compared to other men
well she Compares them as an alpha
amongst the other men so so then he he's
capable of leading her but he's not
married
yeah but the but the problem is even
when you guys were saying earlier like
the majority of what percent of men are
really leading their women
you know it's a complex question because
like man can see men as an alpha and
women I see that man as an alpha yeah
and being loud and void that doesn't
make you illegal you know there's quiet
man who can lead like some of the most
you know wealthy men you don't hear them
anywhere but they are the effectively
the leader so I think is is what you
Dean is that alpha or that beta I think
it just depends on perspective yeah but
I mean at the end of the day women only
want 20 of men
so yeah but so but isn't a cat a beta be
a great husband absolutely yeah yeah
no they cannot be a great husband
because he's not sure of himself
that's that's why he's Veda like a man
who's not sure of himself and who can be
controlled or manipulated by a woman
he's going to be a terrible husband
because women are chaotic and they're
indecisive and he's going to try to make
you happy in your indecision he's going
to be unstable he's not sure of himself
and he is incapable of being a good
husband
only want that that yeah but that only
lasts for so long exactly yeah those
women hate their husbands though you
don't talk about women she can control
everything he's like seeing the pool boy
or something on the side I don't know
but it's just it still begs the question
like what do what do women do right
because we say hypergamy is a good thing
right but at the same time like women
only want 20 of men
so do you think the the option is they
lower their standards or they share
oh
yeah the majority y'all need a Louis
Austin
why well I mean everybody's not
beautiful everybody doesn't qualify for
the top left top man unless you want to
share
I mean he'll smash anybody yeah
I say ladies keep what you want go buy a
bullet and got to get your nice mattress
because you're gonna be living by
yourself keep what you want right and
let the women who are qualified go for
the men that they can get and have them
that's what I say and so you think the
the other woman should just die alone
okay okay
[Laughter]
let's answer that question I'm gonna say
we might have to lower these standings I
mean you have to
think if you're single and it's been
this way for so long you got to try
something different you can't you can't
keep upholding that that mentality that
lifestyle that you live in because it's
not giving you nowhere so you have to
lower your standards
um you got the rest until like your
femininity and and just try to see where
it gets you
see the problem with that Jr is I'm
concerned with is if you tell women to
lower the standards she's going to show
that man she lowered her she's gonna
make him feel like she lowered her
standards it's going to be a terrible
thing for her so in my I agree with me
to adjust their standards because if you
get into your mind that you settled that
man's gonna feel that and as soon as you
get a whiff of another dude that that
you think that you could have you're
gonna be you're going to resent your man
and if the opportunity to present
yourself you're going to cheat on them
right so I'll tell you women adjust
yourself and be realistic about you
because a lot of women want stuff that
they don't qualify for hey sorry but if
you adjust Lord however you want to chop
it up it's still a possibility yeah you
know we're just giving some factual
advice from a man's perspective on what
you need to do so until that woman makes
the decision as far as if she's going to
do that
you can say uh been a little bit adjust
lower she's got to change that mindset I
agree would you guys rather like share a
guy that you really like or stay with a
guy that you kind of like
and he's not faithful but he's like okay
you kind of like him or get or share a
guy that you really really like you're
sharing the guys that they like right
now
wait why don't I really like him
um let's say how many things you want in
a guy what are your what are your
standards how many things you want
I'm I'm five five things okay he has
what should we give him two what do you
guys think two of them two out of five
well should we give them three three
okay one guy has three out of the five
things you want one guy has five out of
the five things you want
I'll go with a three out of the five but
three out of five yeah okay and you
wouldn't that was sorry to not share
them so not sure yeah I think I agree
with you completely yeah I don't want to
share it yeah I don't want to share
what are what are the five things I'm
curious
um assertive masculine oh it goes okay
yeah I get it yeah
um a great leader provider protector
okay so
um five five and feminine five five yeah
I took out two you said five you're
sharing him I'm sharing yeah
and it's not it's not even the five five
part it's the feminine part I don't want
a feminine yeah that's right but so it's
kind of cap you know what I mean like
yeah I I think it's like that fun but I
think most girls would rather show the
guy they like
yeah I'd rather share them exactly
that's exactly sure
[Music]
do you think most as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible